[Music]
hello and welcome to episode 39 of
GameSpot after dark game spots official
video game podcast
I'm your host Jake Decker and joining me
this week is Lucy James hello jean-luc
psyche hi and Kelly pledgee hello how's
everyone doing all enjoy that Ubisoft
livestream I mean like I love I love
boss logic but the stream was like what
8 hours long so do the reveal to like
the time period and stuff so it's kind
of like well this is cool I like seeing
this happen but I know what they're
building too
yeah I mean I feel awful I didn't watch
the entire stream but I did watch
yourself released that time-lapse of it
after so I was like I'm just gonna
school time yeah that's what I did
oh wait I'll watch the time-lapse no but
boss logic is like oh my god he's so
talented
I'm obsessed like I've followed his
Instagram and his to Aaron all the
collapse he's done for quite a while now
and so when they were like oh we're
gonna do a stream for about Assassin's
Creed like his name being attached I was
like okay yeah it's gonna cool I'm into
it yeah that was a pretty neat idea it's
cool they reached out and did something
like that as opposed to just your
typical I don't know press release
reveal trailer sort of deal although I
guess they do have a trailer coming
right well yeah so by the time this goes
change me out oh it's a it's your blur
classic blessed Studios classic CGI
reveal trailer um so I don't know when
we're gonna get gameplay for Valhalla
but like CGI trailer looks really cool I
think they always do a really good job
with those the main guy I think his
name's Ivor looks a hell of a lot like
Charlie Hunnam but he had a way better
accent I can't talk my accent is all
over the place is terrible but the
Charlie Hunnam Zack sin cuz he's
actually from where I'm from in the UK
the north of England and Newcastle he
actually lives he
grew up down the road from my mom weird
his accent is the most bizarre
amalgamation of Geordi like cockney an
American and I know it's rich for me to
say it but I feel like as someone with a
mangled accent I can say it but anyway I
want to say that to an American your
accent sounds just like British to us to
me it
recently I have sounded American like
painfully Americans sometimes I'll say
something and I'll go oh but it's not
like in a bad way it's more it's more
kind of like a losing your identity way
Lucy but we're still in the office right
before right before we left the office
you walked by something and you said
what's all this then but I do really
want to hear you
full majority that's I have yet to hear
you go flow and I want to hear it I do
actually have I'm kind of doing a lot
but not because I've got a call with my
mom and my uncle my uncles
I mean Annie on Saturday so it's more
like I sound like this like you
mispronounce every single it's weird
because like I'm trying to do it to kind
of give you an example but if I'm on the
phone to my mom it just switches like
very early on when my boyfriend and I
were dating he was playing a game or
something and my mum rang me and I
answered and he just turned around cuz
he was like and what happened to my
girlfriend yeah but my my real accent
yeah I take in the accents of people
around me and so even even usually when
I get drunk that's when it comes out but
when I'm drunk around Americans I take
on American accent mmm
that's why I haven't heard it yeah I do
a similar thing but with Midwestern
things the more I talked to my
Midwestern family you get the mom man
Chicago California good I like that yeah
it's fun
anyway anyway should we talk video games
if we must yeah at some point
Callie do you want to talk about Animal
Crossing your Animal Crossing corner
Animal Crossing corner let's go I have
been playing uh I started playing Doom's
it's not just Animal Crossing for me
anymore but it's a lot of Animal
Crossing is my life so I've just been
working on helping everyone identify
which paintings are forged
because jolly red has come formally
crazy red there's some so in older
Animal Crossing games you
they were just fake it random so you
would buy a painting and it would just
be fake hmm and you'd be screwed and
then starting a new leaf you could
actually identify fakes by differences
but some of the fakes from new leaf are
dif what they're different in new
horizons and I'm so disappointed cuz
like the scary painting which is a
Japanese like EW I print of a an actor
he's like he's like he looks angry and
he's like pointing but in the new leaf
the fake version was doing finger guns
and the fake the valiant statue which is
the it's the winged victory of
samothrace I don't know perhaps it's
like an ancient Greek statue headless
angel thing and nearly the fake version
had bat wings and I'm so disappointed
that it's not like that however one of
the cool things that's been coming out
like today and yesterday is that some of
the fake art is like haunted yeah I
still got in slack and I was like oh ya
know so I would want to get a house of
just the haunted off exactly so it's
pretty cool like somebody right now like
as of Wednesday today we haven't found
it in our own games like we have a
selection we're talking about it and
once we do find it will like confirm the
story but there's like tons of tweets
about it it's not like the kind of thing
that like like huh we've seen the same
thing multiple times not the kind of
thing somebody would fake but I saw like
the graceful painting which is beauty
looking back it's another Japanese
painting
fake version like has a ghostly image on
the back there is a an ancient Japanese
statue the fake version is like actually
an alien and it looks slows yeah it's
it's super cold the the creepiest one
that I've seen so far is a girl the
Pearl Earring or with a Pearl Earring
mm-hmm or is it though I always forget
um I'm like getting it confused with the
girl at the Dragon Tattoo
I think it's a Pearl Earring uh that is
the wistful painting in New Horizons and
she will if she has her eyes closed
she'll open them
Oh No thank you so I can't wait to buy
some fake after trying to buy the real
ones I'm trying to get all these images
for our guide so our guide has like real
and fake one side by side and part of
the reason that I'm so like I vet these
things vigorously is because there's a
lot of misinformation about Animal
Crossing out there so I like to confirm
stuff myself or you know confirm it as
gamespot how I put it in the guide
yeah don't trust it talk no clowns can't
trust tick-tock with your animal
crossing' guides if that needed to be
said yeah so we've been doing a lot of
work as a team to get all these images
together but I you know I'm I have a
very straight shooter in Animal Crossing
I don't time-travel I play by the rules
I don't catch bugs and fish in the
southern hemisphere I'm I'm very I'm
very straight edge do what you want but
I I just I'm like that so I've been
buying the real art because I want to
donate it and make blathers happy but
now we really want the haunted fake art
so cuz you could can you only buy one a
day a one per visit but so you can buy
that's not anything we learned you can
buy art from red on somebody else's
Island oh he can have multiple
legitimate paintings or statues per day
because there are some that don't have
it a fake version there's like like
starry night there's no fake sorry night
or twinkling painting as it is called
and
you can have a friend come and buy that
other one or buy one of your fakes
you're you're just limited to one per
day in on any Island so if like I have
red and you have red then you can't come
by for my red and your red right but
like tomorrow
I have red today if you came about
something and then you had red tomorrow
I could come by something from you so
that's nice and helpful yeah I was able
to to get the Great Wave off Kanagawa so
what if I had
what if someone has two characters on
their island could so they could only
buy one thing from red between those two
characters or could each of those
characters buy one thing from red
because I'm very tempted to make another
character and just throw them on my
Island just so I can double up on these
events cuz right now it seems like it's
gonna take a very long time to get all
the paintings I guess I would say that
multiple character like you it's one per
character and the only reason I would
say that is because you can have
multiple legitimate paintings a day
which seems to be like a throw somebody
a bone for being player - yes it's just
like my character couldn't buy two
pieces from red even if I went to
another Island right right okay
interesting so I mean I haven't
confirmed that I would love to know if
that's true or not yeah that is my hunch
because the stuff if you're not the main
player on the island you kind of get
screwed over like you can't help
Gulliver if the other player has already
helped Gulliver so if you're like the
second person who gets to play it did
that for that day there you're kind of
getting the short end of the stick
in my opinion so that's why I would
assume that it's her character not her
like I would say I will say I love red
and like his whole aesthetic he's got
going with his with his boat in the back
that's like sketchy and about to fall
apart and it's really dark and dimly lit
and then he just takes you back with all
these prize paintings there's like take
your pick and then you'd have to figure
like I I genuinely really enjoy that and
I'm happy it made it back in animal
crossing this soon like I think
we all knew that red would return in
some form but I'm happy he's already
here because I don't know like one thing
I really loved in the older Animal
Crossing games is that there's always
like a scummy nature to some of the
characters and I feel like they're
bringing that back with red and I hope
Lyle will come back in some form
although I think he was kind of like
straightened up in new leaf but I do
miss how he'd come to your house and try
to show you life insurance policies that
were just a waste of money and wouldn't
do anything and they follow you around
all day
I love his his when you get the painting
from him and like the email or the
letter it says like oh thanks for
getting this like very legit and yeah
you know no refunds by the way just like
grunkle Stan from the show gravity falls
I don't know if any of you guys are
familiar with that he's he's like a
sleazy like salesman who makes like fake
like spooky stuff that like he sells to
like tourists and stephenie he just he
has that same energy of like you're
scummy but also very charming and I love
you do you the connection between him
and Tom Nook because once okay that was
good according to the internet they're
like they have some past beef or maybe
they used to be there an ex-couple and
I'm like is this just the internet make
an up [ __ ] or if the entire making up
[ __ ] they're not a couple okay I mean if
you want like like CJ definitely
boyfriends I mean I did take the red
carpet but I I was like their house was
there some sort of connection between
them in the past gains at all but this
is coming from or is it what a hundred
percent fabricated I Animal Crossing
story mode I really hope that focuses in
on the relationship and seeing red and
Tom Nook because I think there's a lot
there yeah well maybe that's it maybe
yeah like maybe whether they were a
partnership and red wanted to go to
dealing wine dodgy dealings um nice play
one thing that's interesting if you have
animal crossing games before is that he
used to be crazy red and now he's jolly
red
I like the pirate rebrand I think it
fits the modern times mm-hmm you know
because he could be an Internet pirate
as well but I I know that Nintendo has
wanted to move away from the crazy
branding for a while so that's one thing
that they did and then also like they
kind of did that did like a rebrand on a
lot of characters cuz like flicking CJ
it's like the big boa fication
of the previous like bug off dude he
there they were ugly designs like Joan
the turnip she's like she's rough they
made her cute they made Daisy male so I
think they're just they're like let's do
a nice refresh let's make red jolly
instead of crazy because that's iffy so
yeah I fun fact about red that makes
sense I'm excited to play more and I'm
excited for Mayday and of course we'll
keep you updated on all the animal
crossing updates but anyway jean-luc
both of us from playing this game but do
you want to kick it off yeah yeah we
were playing Final Fantasy 14 together
are you not feeling it anymore
you're shaking your head no I'm just I
have very mixed feelings about it and
I'm going to be very unhappy if if it
does other expansions aren't as good as
people tell me they are ou might get
more in there get more into it later my
team is gonna blow up if it doesn't pan
out yeah I'm waiting for the big update
and is it July mmm yes oh I kept all
that stuff so what happened to me was I
started the night before they announced
that update and I bought time I was like
okay I'm gonna play this I saw jean-luc
playing it and Matt was interested in
playing it and Ben said he could help us
so I was like okay I'm gonna give this
another shot and then the next day
they're like hey guess what we're
cutting a lot of the story the original
story and I was like thank God I just
bought time this is perfect and then I
find out it's actually in July yeah and
I was like well my time expires by then
so I better play it now so I am playing
it now I won't say too much but I
I like I have fun playing with friends
but you can say that about a lot of
games but it is so yeah dull in my
opinion I don't like the combat that
much because it's very MMO II if you
like that combat awesome I don't
and then the story it's just like I skip
through all of it because I just don't I
I have no interest in any of it I don't
want to dominate the conversation gently
because I'm sure you have other you have
many opinions as well but I'll just
leave it at that like I mean right now I
am forcing myself through this thing and
I hope it's better if it doesn't I'm
gonna are gonna beat up Michael or
something I'm six feet away yeah thanks
Adam you're mostly right I feel pretty
much the same way like I think the
combat is pretty whatever to me like it
especially coming off of something like
Final Fantasy 7 with that combat so good
and it totally click that button wait
through the cooldown and click the other
button and okay now I can do this attack
and I'm like I don't know what I'm I'm
just hitting the buttons and things are
happening and at least right now and
like the early parts like I you look at
raids and it's like clearly these people
are coordinating on some level but I
think like early MMO combat it it feels
like it doesn't matter what button I hit
like one attack versus the other like
both of these do you would attack I
don't know like so I find I'm with you I
find MMO combat pretty dull I'm trying
to pay more attention to the story just
because I know that the characters
they're setting up our characters that
continue into those other expansions
where the story actually gets good so
I'm like at least trying to somewhat
like pay attention to the characters and
be like okay hopefully I'll have at
least some idea of who these characters
are when the story gets good it's it is
still pretty dull I'm what they said
they were cutting like 13% of the
content which is honestly like enough ah
yeah I mean I some of its good like I've
enjoyed the dungeon stuff we did like a
boss battle against III that was pretty
cool mmm
I like the areas like it's fun wandering
around like you know we were talking
when we were playing about how like well
the desert area is like pretty cool and
you know I guy there are elements I'm
enjoying about it but yeah it's still a
lot of being an MMO and being like all
right I'm gonna get to this area and
then this guy's gonna be like I need you
to go pick up five bottles okay well and
I've actually been grinding even more
than you because when we started playing
we all picked DPS characters and then we
realized we can't do any of the dungeons
together because he has you can have two
dps one tank and one healer and we're
like okay well only two of us can ever
be in the same done it at the same time
so it's like oh so just add in their
matchmaking for dungeons can take like
15 minutes really long because we're
only DPS so we need a tank and a healer
and if you don't have that you're gonna
like you it will sit outside of a
dungeon he had then been joined just
once but he hasn't joined us since then
but we'll sit outside of a dungeon we'll
see all these other characters walk up
that are clearly DPS too and it's just
like hey you're here too
you're waiting for some healers and then
you see he would come up and then like a
couple other people disappear you're
like well there goes my chance of
getting in that dungeon because if
you're playing by yourself you're gonna
pick a DPS character you know like no
one's gonna be like I play mmo's by
myself I'll pick the white mage like no
one's gonna do that
the thing that I like about the game
that other mmo's don't really do is that
you can play multiple classes without
having to remake a whole new character
like like you can just play any class
regardless but your level is tied to
that class so I said okay why don't I
get a second class as a conjurer so that
we can have a healer and that can
hopefully make it easier we can play
together but I had to start at level 1
and I've been like slowly grinding so I
think like our main characters are level
like 23 25 my conjurer is right now at
level 12 and I'm just going through like
the area and finding all of the like
really boring quests that we didn't do
and like doing those
to like power up my second character and
I was just like man this is really dull
yeah I'm really tempted to buy like a
level skip or something which is not
great I don't want to do that but also I
feel like I don't want to grind out this
second character just so we can play
dungeons together yeah I mean I just say
like as as difficult as it is for me to
get into I do I do like the world I
think it's I think it looks great and it
does a good job of areas not feeling -
mm Oh II like here's your news your
enchanted forest here's your like it
that's still there but it feels it feels
like there's more character and
personality to those areas which I do
like and so the characters I kind of
like here and there and and the
customization I think is is great like
seeing how people look the only thing I
will say is that I'm like level 30
something that or I'm 26 I think 27 and
I still look like a freakin NPC I've got
like like a beige towel
might as well be just a beige towel over
me and like the most generic looking
sword actually I'd go as far to say that
NPCs look cooler than me because I've
seen plenty of NPCs but I've walked up
to with like just like a suit of armor
and I'm like wow I wonder if that'll be
me one day in 20 hours or so and then
every time you go to a main town like
the hub area has just tons of players
and they all look so cool you're like
like that person's like like a 9 foot
tall bunny lady and with like Bayonetta
looking outfit and like you know they
like it's just like been always
described Final Fantasy as the devianart
of mmo's and I think that's comparison
but everyone just looks insane and I'm
like this is great like I want to look
like this and I'm like yeah like you
said I'd put like I don't know at least
20 hours into this game at this point I
basic ass armor and I'm just like when
do I get the little [ __ ] wood boat that
looks like I could have made it in my
backyard
so yeah that's been interesting art it's
fun you guys yeah and Sundin it's fun
playing with magic but yeah my tech said
I could technically have that experience
with any game I like definitely get the
social appeal to mmo's because I've
never really played an MMO but like it
is fun to just go to the hub area with
your friends and like [ __ ] around mess
around dance do all the other random
[ __ ] people do in those kind of games
but like when I'm like I read I'm gonna
grind some levels by myself I'm like
banging my head against my desk as I do
it it's rough I just I can never get
into an MMO in that way like you can buy
like time shares in that game and I'm
liking shadows look at like a house you
can buy a house and they have you have
to like pay a monthly rent to keep that
house because there are limited slots
and someone else could take that house
so there was a there was a story when it
was real money with yes with or a real
in-game money it might be it might be
in-game money but basically there was a
there was a story that happened when all
the Cova 19 business happened where they
had canceled rent for your in-game house
because they were like some players
might not be able to log on so and we
don't want them to lose their house so
we have cancelled your fake in game
final fantasy house rent so that you can
hopefully pay your real because you
might not be able to log in the final
fantasy come on is is better than her
own god well I'm gonna piss off the
Final Fantasy fans in this in this
episode I think cuz so I actually
haven't been playing Final Fantasy 7 but
I've been watching watching a lot of
stuff rewatching areas I've done our
areas in the game and I still really
like that game it's still one of my
favorite game
of 2020 I think it's great I think
everyone should play it but I have
soured a lot on it just thinking about
it thinking about mm-hmm
the the things I still really like
though that I will say I think the
characters are still fantastic and I
think the combat is great the combat is
better than great in my opinion I'd
loved it but just like I'm watching
scenes and I don't like the writing the
most of the writing just lacks a lot of
subtext for me so a Kingdom Hearts fan
cuz yeah horrible [ __ ] that is in my
eyes remarkably reined in so if you take
what you don't like about Final Fantasy
and I say this with love as a Kingdom
Hearts fan and just multiply it by ten
that's what Kingdom Hearts 3 was too I
would say maybe it's the Rose tinted
glasses because I played it when I was
so much younger but I feel like the
rains were kind of like he was kept on a
rein for seven realization was different
and and I think that's why I enjoyed it
as I was playing through it but watching
scenes back and like seeing different
gameplay and lines I just liked it I
find all of its so cringy and hard to
listen to and part of it may be that I
am playing with the English voiceover
like maybe that's just how that
voiceover is maybe if I played with subs
instead in Japanese that would be much
better but it still doesn't really it
still doesn't really fix that I think
there's just like it's lacking in so
much subtext at least between the
dialogue between characters obviously I
think the world in how you're the heroes
are portrayed I think are very good and
have a lot to them and that is super
impressive like I said I really like the
characters but man I like looking I've
just it's crazy how much I've kind of
soured on it like and I think the big
thing the big thing is the ending like
when I first I won't say I know spoilers
here but when I first saw the ending I
didn't understand it and I was like well
it's probably because I didn't play the
original and I don't know much about
Final Fantasy 7 so I reached out talked
to more he explained it to me and I was
like okay that makes sense
I just kind of went with it and the more
I've thought about it the more I'm just
like this is so stupid like this ending
is like absurd and part of it too I
think maybe because I did decide to play
Final Fantasy 7 the original and I got
to that point and I think I like how the
original handles it more and I think
part of that is because I have to fill
in way more of the blanks by myself so
it's like I yeah I don't know it's
interesting and like I do in a preface
like if you're loving Final Fantasy 7 if
you really liked Final Fantasy 7 remake
like I still like it I'm not saying you
can't like it
I'm just saying personally it's been
it's been a really weird experience
because I came off so high on that game
and now the more I think about it the
more I'm just like I don't know if I
liked it as much as I thought I did I've
had a oh sorry you can go first
like you know it's really rare because
most the time we give opinions we're
telling you you're horrible and you
shouldn't play that's all I had well
actually I wanted to ask a follow-up
question in for a more serious thing is
how did you end up liking the characters
if you didn't like the dialogue like
what about the characters shown through
not through that kinda stuff that's
weird right because I the I didn't like
the dialogue itself like I thought it
was cheesy and hard to listen to but I
it's also kind of genuine like it feels
like I don't know it's really hard to
explain but I think the interactions
between the characters worked so well I
feel about deaths your ending where it's
like some of these yeah it's kind of
cheesy but it's so earnest yeah yeah I
think this is yeah but you got worse
though and worse isn't the bat isn't the
right word but I don't I don't think it
works as well maybe we had this
discussion in a slack channel about is
is Final Fantasy 7 remake like super
anime and one of the things that like
the anime fans in the office were
arguing was that it sounds more soap
opera a than like like not all anime is
just like
my gosh like super dramatic it seems to
be it's not the from I haven't played it
yet it sounds like it's very soap opera
fish which has its own charms but if
you're not like used to that kind of
delivery maybe it's I would say the
kijima comparisons pretty apps like
Metal Gear I would describe more as like
a soap opera with anime elements to it
so I would say Final Fantasies like that
I'm kind of with you Jake and that I
have my opinion is definitely not soured
I would say but like I thinking more
about it there are elements that I don't
like as much that I were fine with that
first but then there are some stuff I
still like even more like I do think I
really like some of the character
moments some of the dialogue the DES
like it should be I think my favorite
parts are when the characters are acting
with each other and their interactions
are like really good like Aerith
interacting with cloud and and like Tifa
and like Barratt like i think that's
when the games out its best the more I
think about the ending I do agree that
it has a lot of problems and it's like
the way they handled it was it's just
kind of weird I I can't really say it
without going into it I don't wanna but
yeah for you don't want spoiler but it's
one of those things where it's like what
it seemed like they're trying to go with
they could have done without doing what
they did if that makes yeah that and and
and I'm sort of fine with it like I'm
sort of like you know what that's fine
like that's the way they wanted to do it
I respect that as like a vision I'm
still very excited to see the next part
that's nothing like when yeah two comes
out that's gonna be like that's gonna be
a day one purchase for me because like I
said I fell in love with those
characters I think they're all so great
and I want to see where it goes but just
like I don't know seeing a lot of those
scenes back and like thinking about some
of the sections like the robot hands
stuff is just like I kind of liked how
the original game handled the robot hand
stuff or it was just like there it is I
don't need to interact with it at all
yeah that is maybe one of the few parts
the game where they're like we need to
fill this out to make it a longer game
because it's yeah yeah sell it the one
that I still really hate is when people
complain that this is just a cash grab
the only reason they separated it sounds
just for a cash grab just because this
game is 40 hours long I think there are
areas that drag and there is padding but
what game doesn't do that especially
RPGs what RPGs don't do that and I think
like the game is predominantly pretty
lean and has all the important stuff in
there for you I 100% agree I you know
and any games gonna have its issues but
by calling it a cash grab is is so
reductive and dismissive of all the hard
work that went into that game I think
that's a really terrible argument I
won't even like entertain ya but anyway
Lucy you're still playing it how has it
been treating you good I really enjoy it
I mean I'm not at the ending yet I'm in
chapter 15 oh you're close yes I'm close
I'm I went past the point of no return
but I'm still enjoying it a lot I'm
gonna play some more tonight but I've so
we don't kind of talk about final
fantasy too much
I've also still been playing overwatch
cuz echos out now ah
I've spent a couple weeks playing her
she's good but god she's powerful she's
really powerful and she like she's the
last hero coming to overwatch before two
launches so hopefully God hopefully that
means it's launching this year with like
another new hero cuz everyone thought it
wasn't gonna be EKKO everyone thought it
was gonna be oh I don't even remember
the name but it was a character who like
had appeared in a short before he's like
a French sounding name I don't remember
but the Necker came out she's great but
sure she's kind of high-risk high-reward
because she doesn't have a very big
health pool I think she's just at 200
and so she died super easily but on the
flip side she has a tiny hitbox she has
a get-out-of-jail-free card that's
basically her movement ability is kind
of like Farah where you can just like
shoot up into the air
her main fire is super
powerful then she has this alt fire
which is sticky bombs that attach onto
not just an enemy but you can attach it
onto a wall so it's like you can kind of
technically do area-denial with lower
health enemies and then she has a beam
because of course why shouldn't she have
a beam that does like double damage to
enemies if they're half health and then
on top of that her all is that she can
turn into any member of the opposing
team and gets her all charged I think
it's like six hundred percent faster so
yeah she's incredible and I had like one
game where I was absolutely destroying
as her and I was like oh my god I'm an
echo main now and then the next game I
was absolutely terrible and I died all
the time so like okay mom like to the
drawing board but she's really fun
I just don't think in terms of like the
grandeur overwatch meta as it stands
right now if she's maybe the shot in the
arm that it kind of needs I would have
said I would have preferred a different
type and you tank or and you heal but
she's good I like her a lot we've been
spending a lot of time playing so is
that all everyone picks like when you go
into a match that hard to get her first
day yes
after that it's been fairly easy okay to
get her yeah it just she doesn't fit all
play styles I would say like I
specifically don't play Genji because
I'm not quick enough and maybe that's
the reason why sometimes I have really
bad games as echo whereas I never humble
brag never you have a bad game is like
diva or Moira because I just I don't
know I intrinsically understand those
characters a bit better
whereas with Genji I have no idea how
Genji Saltworks
and I have like 500 hours at least into
overwatch and I cannot for the life of
me play Genji that's it it's my games
alright then we move on to the news this
week
nothing happened what you're talking
about it's been read quite week I kind
of wish nothing happens for one of those
stories but I guess we'll start with the
cyberpunks first rating has been leaked
I think it was like
where's the rating in Brazil and it is a
long list of things that it's basically
everything you would expect every yeah
everything you've seen on the back of a
box on the mature rating or 18 plus
rating is in here god speed to Australia
I know yeah yeah that's gonna be really
interesting because it is it is a long
long rap sheet here I won't read through
it just in case people are worried about
spoilers or maybe want to keep all that
fresh but one I guess interesting thing
that happened which shouldn't be that
surprising because it CD Projekt RED
Pavel Sisko I think one of the creative
level designer one of the lead level
designers tweeted the leak and was just
like yeah well we don't we don't really
[ __ ] around right and yeah is there's
some there's some like things on there
that I've never actually seen on the
back of a box so it's like alright what
this is prostitution although I don't
read too many although I will say like
this is the Brazilian rating like this
is the in-depth one so not all this
stuff always appears on the back of a
box a lot of it is truncated into one
word like like I'm sure prostitution for
our rating system would yeah it would
fall under sexual themes I didn't even
know this happened
mrs. somehow so I kind of want you to
say a few of the crazy ones but that's
just me I can't crazy ones me too okay
well I guess if you don't want to hear
this maybe skip ahead a little bit 30
seconds 30 seconds alright hold on I got
a I got to find some good ones here I
mean priority set prostitution I think
that was a pretty good one intentional
death okay alright
description of illicit drug consumption
or trafficking okay um blood injury
blood injury foul language this is the
Brazilian one so I I feel like it's
translated a little weird consume of
illicit drugs sexual pleasure mint can't
think I didn't see that one furball
aggression criminal action without
violence okay why is that white-collar
crime that's like probably I mean if you
can play as a yes I mean like I said a
lot of his stuff you won't actually see
on the back of the box but these are
just like a more in-depth breakdown none
of its really that spoiler area like I
think a lot of this stuff if you look
through it you should expect it yeah at
least what they've teased yeah but I I
don't know that's kind of interesting
and also just like it kind of at least
in my mind hopefully reconfirms that CD
Projekt RED is gonna hit that release
date cuz I've always thought I know what
I'll do if it gets pushed what it's like
to be the person at the ESRB because you
don't apparently play the game they just
send you like a clips of their the worst
stuff so you're like essentially just
getting like a montage so imagine you're
like haven't played cyberpunk and that
you just getting a video montage of it's
like like worst moments yeah like a hard
cut from like self-pleasure Minh
self-pleasure meant to like intentional
death or like so Danny actually did a
doc you Danny O'Dwyer of noclip actually
the documentary on that oh really
yeah I don't know if you've checked it
out it it fell under I think was just
the ESRB documentary that he did but he
went in and talked to a lot of people
who do that stuff a lot of it is
confidential because they don't want
people knowing the names of those people
because they don't want developers to
pay people off and be like hey just
ignore this section or whatever so so
it's it's pretty fascinating like they
take that very seriously and one thing
that they pointed out was like not a lot
of developers really try to trick them
cuz like what's the point yeah like you
could just screw yourself over if you
don't and you might as well show
everything that
is in this game that could trigger
someone the one thing they did say was
that occasionally they'll miss something
like they'll send something and forget
something that they didn't think would
be a problem or offensive or something
that like concerned a more stringent
rating but yeah it's super fascinating I
definitely recommend checking it out
anyway any last thoughts about
cyberpunks rating link mm-hmm I want it
want to play it I know me too
so bad imagine if it came out April 16th
we'd be way busier because white well
because right now I'm trying to do Final
Fantasy and persona 5 royal so if you
add cyberpunk into the mix there well I
mean I've not got much else going on but
oh my god I'm still doing Animal
Crossing I mean well I don't know too I
guess
continue on to release dates and delays
in leaks unfortunately this is the
reason why I'm sure a lot of people
won't be checking the comments at least
a lot of people that games problem for
check in comments on videos won't be
don't worry
yeah your tweets is because yeah I mean
The Last of Us too bad leaked and it
should say from the GameSpot YouTube in
comments ID we're trying to do our best
to squash people in the comments from
spoiling things so we're putting words
on mute list for a while I'm sure you
can understand why I did a news story I
did a news video on Monday about ghosts
ghosts and last was getting the numerous
dates and you know I was talking with
Greg my and Jenn my roommates about it
and we were just like genders we can't
but me and Greg were like we're gonna
get this spoiled like there is no way
we're making it to June without I mean
Adams my DM is definitely open I've done
about Greg's minor because we're trying
to encourage people to join the discord
and while like 99% of the people who
messaged me are just like super nice I
just want to again disco
who's gonna be the 1% who's just gonna
send me like I can mute key words all I
want but people send stuff on images so
you can't like Kelly was saying this
someone commented on your Instagram yeah
I I mean I've gotten Instagram comment
harassment in the past my DM thought
have been locked for a very long time
but Instagram comments or one way that
people target you when your DMS are
closed and I I saw some words and those
yeah as soon as I registered that it was
about the last of us I like I was like
the leading blindly like and I like have
like I still am like a beer like so I
mean people are gonna want to ruin
things and yeah it sucks but I
appreciate your sacrifice in in getting
those yes saying I I'm like obviously I
would have been incredible to just
experience the story as no edog intended
but at the same time for me spoilers
aren't really like the be-all and
end-all I'm still definitely gonna play
part two like I'm really invested in
those characters I love what I like
Jake hearing you talk about what it
feels to like to play and see all the
changes they've made it's not about the
destination it's about the journey and
like from the sounds of it I didn't
watch anything I just like saw a few
comments and gleaned what happened and I
was like okay great
I know it you know but like from what it
sounds like the scenes that were
released was specifically incendiary
like they were the things that they knew
that the internet would get riled up
about because unfortunately while a
bunch of people are super-nice there was
still some wrong ends out there who just
hate other people so yeah like some of
the some of the comments I've had to
like go in and delete have been gross
quite frankly and it's like it's
difficult to even find you can't just
put a word
because they're finding inventive ways
of stringing the words together they're
just like this super hurtful and just
like I feel I like I actually kind of
feel sorry for people who live their
lives that way like it's yeah it's gross
but anyway like it [ __ ] sucks with
people a naughty dog imagine working on
a game for like at least seven years and
then just to have someone leak all of
that so close to release like I imagined
that them pushing it from like the may
release date wasn't probably there for
like that idea
I bet Sony was like hey we yeah like
cannot release this game right now we're
gonna have to put it back but also the
distribution is definitely no such yeah
like also the distribution stuff they
can't predict that they can't control
that now things have settled down a
little bit you know it's kind of taken
all the wind out of it and it's like oh
yeah
just imagine being that kind of person
yeah I mean when it happened I saw lots
of people on Twitter complained well I
guess I didn't see myself but I saw lots
of people referencing the fact that a
lot of people were canceling their
pre-orders and mad because of I don't
want to say too much but like mad
because they found out uh things that
happen in the story and where it goes
and some people are disappointed because
it didn't sound exciting enough and it's
like the thing you're saying about it's
the journey not really the end and I
think that is definitely true with the
first/last of us right you can make any
story sound boring yeah but with a
synopsis that's like that's like with
the original essence right like the
whole thing is we just got to get from
one side of the country to the other
yeah
and but what happens in between is
what's so special and incredible about
that game the performances the way those
music are played out like cuz yeah
you're right like Last of Us on paper
you're like oh it's the road with you
know like zombies like it it doesn't the
Last of Us doesn't sound that special on
paper I feel like it's when you play it
that you like yes this is special all of
these elements have come to
like totally and so yeah and I think
like from what I played to right like I
played a couple hours and the gameplay
was so good that like I like I mean
obviously I care about the store and I'm
very excited to see where it goes but I
don't need this grand story to get me
through the game because the gameplay is
so good I like those characters so I
just found it so weird that people were
like up in arms about the plot seeming
too simple or something like that like
it's just like what you know nothing
about the game other than maybe you've
seen these scenes or you've seen someone
spoil it like there's like this is
supposed to be Naughty Dog's longest
game yet so I don't know there's still I
feel like there's still a lot more to be
excited for even though like you're
saying some wrong ones decided to go
through and spoil this for people but
it's still such a it makes me so mad
like I'd I'd be so pissed like I I god I
I feel bad for Neil druckmann too
because everything he tweets people are
just harassing him about why'd you delay
the game why is this happening why can't
we play it release a demo like I can't
believe it's just like the guy has like
is bit along with this entire team's
been working their ass off on this game
and like I know there's been a lot of
controversy controversy with long hours
and whatnot but this is not a way to get
back at them yeah and those people like
to be frank the people who are
complaining in harassing him aren't
people who care about you know like the
working conditions they just care that
they didn't get the game early it's the
same thing that happened with no man's
sky when that game got like delayed like
six weeks and people were sending death
threats to like Jason Schreyer for
reporting it and then the team for doing
it and it was like what are you tying
their like this is the greatest game
ever and I'm so excited for it and I'm
gonna murder you because do you delete
it and you're like that makes no sense
you're a crazy person like it's honestly
like have you ever read so you've been
publicly shamed
by Jon Ronson it's he's a British
documentary maker and he is incredible
he wrote the psychopath test and many
start goats and akhiya he wrote a book
called so you've been public shamed and
honestly it's like for me it's kind of
it's it's I don't worry was people who's
like this book changed me but it it
really made me react salmon how I
conduct myself over social media and
because it's just basically a book
detailing people whose lives were ruined
because of seemingly in some cases
seemingly innocuous things in other
cases in the infamous Justine Sacco the
woman who flew on the plane and she
before she took off she said quote like
going to Africa hope I don't get AIDS
JK I'm white and then how her life was
dismantled by people who would just kind
of like get that pitchforks out and
obviously like what she tweeted was
wrong and it was gross gross tweet but
then there were other people in that
book who like didn't really tweet
anything like that at all and it's just
the way that social media can like
really rip apart your life because of
people who just want to take a fight and
feel like they're doing something the
feel they feel like they're doing
something to kind of police it I guess
and it's weird and that's what I assume
some of these people who were doing who
are like well I don't agree with what's
being portrayed in the Last of Us part
two so I'm gonna try and do my best to
stop it and convince other people to
cancel their pre-orders either by
spoiling the game for them or I don't
know it's weird it's like I recommend
that book I just totally all right go
ahead Ashley they you really never know
what people will pick up on and torture
you over I said that the Xbox ones you I
was bad years ago and sometimes people
still suit me about that and I'm sorry
to say I still think that and I I just
hope I didn't Neil druckmann
still feels like he wants to make games
after this cuz he's got such
such a great voice and a show show first
I know he's making an HBO show first but
I but I hope this doesn't like yeah
because like if I was in his position
I'd be over it I just did again [ __ ] it
like I I've put so much time into this
game that people wanted and they were
very excited for and I'm super proud of
it and now because of a delay people are
pissed at me a delay I can't control and
then it gets spoiled and now I'm getting
them and now I'm getting bashed over
this it's just like sometimes I wonder
why anyone sometimes I wonder why anyone
makes games I assumed that it's like
once you cut through the [ __ ] that you
can get on the internet for creating a
game and you get to see the people who
are like your game changed my life
you've got a hope that like that light
is what comes through the darkness that
can be the internet like I remember I
could develop I got death threats
because they have two sniper rifle or
something years ago and I was like oh
yeah really it's so yeah it astounds me
that people make games at all yeah going
back to going back to no man's sky the
amount of respect I have for Shaun
Murray it's like yeah insane yeah
they've really turned it around to like
I mean they came out on the other side
of that in like the best possible way
and but like holy crap yeah I mean not
that he had to turn it around or
anything like that but just the the fan
response now is like so positive for
that game like the the community the
reddit community bought a billboard
outside their office a couple years ago
that just said thank you for making this
amazing game we love you and stuff like
that and they had no idea and it's just
like okay well that's that's kind of
nice to see but anyway to continue on to
the Last of Us the Last of Us did get a
release date it's coming on on June 19th
and ghosts of Tsushima got delayed about
a month to what is it July so those
games are on the way I I'd imagine the
ghost of Tsushima delay was mostly just
to give last of us enough space to
breathe speculation but that would be my
guess but yeah that's exciting I was
worried I figured those games or I
figured less was too
come out until like fall yeah oh yeah I
think we were throwing around August me
just got pushed no glad but anyway
listen her questions do I take the first
one Kelly sure sometime last year I
bought Hyrule warriors for the Wii U
since it was cheap I found that it
wasn't really user friendly for me as I
had a severe visual impairment the color
scheme was a bit too dark the text was
hard to read and some important text in
dialogue with Auto Scrolls so I didn't
even have time to sweat to read it one
thing that I think would make the game
more accessible is more voice acting but
asking for something as crazy as that
for a small group of people feels like
too much I really think game companies
should focus on making games more
accessible but how much is too much
that is from swishy pixel on discord hi
I'm the answer yeah go um
I think like so the voice acting example
I think that's a really difficult one
because of localization so that's why
you don't see a lot of voice acting in
certain games is because that's so much
more expensive to then get all that
voice acting redone if you want to read
uh bit however I think there are other
solutions between what Hyrule warriors
offered and voice acting that would make
it a lot more accessible like I am just
nearsighted I don't have like a specific
visual impairment but I also because of
my anxiety I have a really hard time
focusing sometimes and so games that
don't auto scroll are really helpful
because sometimes I have to read the
text multiple times or games that have
like text logs that you can click into
and read back a conversation are really
really helpful so that's one thing
bigger text having text size options
other like sound cues and then also
lighting is one of those things so like
I totally get the question but I would
say that it's not asking too much
because I think making games more
accessible improves the experience for
everybody like I don't need quote
unquote need those accessibility options
but that would make the experience
for me too so it's like you're not
really losing when developers add things
like that
I think the voice-acting example is just
one that's like really costly so maybe
that's I wouldn't say that asking too
much but maybe that's not something
that's as I was kissed accessible to the
developers I don't want success you can
say like achievable visible it's yeah
feasible I don't think it's like too
much asked to raise the standards making
something like I think a game that is
accessible like easy to follow easy to
the Texas easy to read that's just good
design like I don't think I think that
pushes games toward better and better
designs so yeah I would say good oh
sorry well you finish
oh I'm just going to say one thing I
noticed an animal crossing that I wanted
to mention forgot to mention as an
example of this it's a minor thing but
the art has differences and one of them
I thought the difference was just color
and I'll well that kind of sucks with
you're colorblind or you can't tell
apart blue and purple but there's
actually another difference in the
painting that is just like physical it's
not color based so there's like enough
of a difference maybe you couldn't see
different colors so like something like
that it's like like colorblind options
is a great example of like that's like
doesn't seem like a big ask and lots of
games have done it yeah we are gently oh
yeah sorry Johnny
oh I was just gonna say like even an
extreme example I've seen games do you
like implement like a text-to-speech
where it'll just have like a AI robot
like renew menu and my next businesses
sorry so like as long as they there's
other creative ways you can have that
where it's like I agree like at the at
the front they should just have the text
be easier to read but like you know they
can have things for people who are like
I am basically blind and I need
something else that is like you know
pretty cost effective solution I I
always feel like games can do more and
and I get that it's like really tough
because I feel like a lot of game like
it's one of those things were
it's not malicious like I think game
developers just don't think about that
stuff as often like an interesting
example is like outer wilds our wild
spot of worlds gone it's gonna happen
nineteen still haunting us there was
like that story about how that game's
color palette the game doesn't have a
colorblind mode because the game's color
palette naturally works for colorblind
people because one of the game's
directors is colorblind and that's the
case where well they thought about that
because one of the creative leads was in
that situation and was able to think
about that and I know like I think
Microsoft has like that really big
document they put out I was going to say
that accessibility thing and then shout
out Microsoft because they are the
people who are like not to say that
other game developers on but they when
John Luke when you I you me Richard and
Tom went to talk to Rod Fergusson last
year he we're talking about like Jack
one of the characters from Gears but he
was saying that like the amount of
accessibility options in Gears five
which are incredible and game makers
toolkit did a really good video about it
a astounding and he basically said that
like they want to take so he used an
example of subtitles so when you're at
the gym or an airport and there's a news
report on there are subtitles but it's
like subtitles were designed for people
who were hard of hearing they weren't
built for people who could hear because
like they could just hear it but the
fact that it's like what was it solved
for one expand too many I think was the
phrase that he used and he said that
like that's why accessibility is so
important at the coalition and it
Microsoft and they actually do inclusive
design Sprint's at all Microsoft Studios
obviously they have the adaptive
controller but they work really hard on
things like subtitles they can change
colors on subtitles in size so people
can read them and it's just super cool
learning about that because it's
something that we wouldn't necessarily
need or use but the fact that it's there
I think it was it Ubisoft saying that in
Assassin's Creed Odyssey
they put subtitles on by default
and it was something like 90% of people
kept them on and so yeah and like they
they do cool things with that too and
like being able to resize your subtitles
and it's yeah to use the Microsoft
slogan like when we all play we all win
kind of thing and it's just good to see
them more companies all embracing that
now so we've forgot to Hyrule warriors
they're probably not going to patch that
in but looking ahead it's something that
definitely more game developers are
certainly thinking about and we didn't
even mention the adaptive controller for
like accessibility like Microsoft has
really been crushing it yeah I think
Microsoft specifically like I think all
developers should think about it but
Microsoft has that like extra like
responsibility because they're like a
platform holder that they can they can
kind of make that more of a mandate and
they have like I think they're doing a
great job on that and that's one of the
things that I like I wish Sony did that
more I think Nintendo is pretty hit or
miss with accessibility in their games
sometimes they're good other times I
think they're kind of terrible at it
I think there was a video it's a video
or a Twitter thread that was like death
strandings failed like all fives like
tests of like accessibility like
colorblind like you know hard of hearing
like it was not great I think they did
actually patch some of that in to make
it better like they were hearing those
complaints but like I'm hoping that more
companies like Sony and Nintendo start
start doing that like well the way Xbox
is and like Microsoft like I think an
important thing to note is it's not just
Microsoft being like we should be more
accessible they're like talking to like
AbleGamers hmm like actually taking into
account the experiences of the people
who would most benefit from
accessibility options it's not like you
can just be like it'd be cool if we made
this better for people who are hard of
hearing without actually like consulting
with those people for example so a plus
Microsoft's all right next question here
this one's from Dede on discord what
we're what were your goals what were
your goals when you started your career
and what are they
now have they changed it's kind of a big
question we're running out of time I
don't think I ever had a specific goal
in mind I think for me it was just I
wanted to make cool stuff and be
employed but then I mean that's not to
say that I'm not ambitious like I'm
fortunate enough that I've done a lot of
cool things in my career and I don't
ever take that for granted
I don't I wouldn't say I have a
five-year plan there are things that I
would love to do but right now I'm just
having such a good time doing what I'm
doing that I haven't really made inroads
into getting there if that makes sense
I'd say one of my goals that I had when
I started at GameSpot which I knew would
take a long time was start a podcast
because I was wondering when I had
started there wasn't a podcast and I
remember when I first started working at
GameSpot all I do is was was listen to
podcast so I just as an IgM podcast and
I'd always wonder what happened all the
GameSpot podcasts and that's something
that I think I even brought up on my
interview when I first came in I was
like what happened to that and they're
like you know they just we're figuring
out a good way to do it and there was
the lobby to be fair which was a podcast
but I always thought of that more like a
video like I wouldn't just listen to
that I would like I would this in all
the other podcasts and then I'd go home
and watch the lobby so I was always like
I I want like just an audio-only podcast
which is cool that we're doing it I
guess it's not audio only anymore
because we did show up on YouTube but I
still would say that this podcast is
mostly catered to audio yes nurse I
could be wrong if you think I'm wrong
you can let me know and we can see what
we can do about that but I think for the
most part like this podcast is designed
for your earholes
[Music]
I had a really specific goal in the
beginning my career like I really I
specifically wanted to be a Nintendo
editor at IGN I did work at IGN but they
had gotten rid of platform editors
and I was never an editor at IGN I just
wrote a lot of stuff I also was very
sure I would never have to be on camera
because I was a writer and that I was
good at writing and not good at camera
so I was just like oh yeah that doesn't
matter but then like that was like years
and years ago and then I ended up taking
theater classes to improve my confidence
in presentation and then my goal has
evolved to just editing things which I
already do oh and then write dope Animal
Crossing guides yes right and I'll dress
in gags all day long that's I love it
I'm having a great time
yeah like when I was a kid I wanted to
write guys so that's been crucial um
very jolly ass thing and I guess now my
goal is to be you great at it I would
say for me I guess yeah like my goal was
to like become a video editor and like
edit you know videos about video games
and like you know work on live shows and
stuff like that and I that's what I got
pretty early honestly so I has been kind
of weird where I feel like I've been
thinking a lot about like oh like where
would I go next for right now I think
I'm just very satisfied with like
constantly trying to find new things to
do and like improve myself and like not
settle for just like you know oh yeah
that's you know what I always do it
really I feel like if I if I have a week
where I'm just kind of like grinding
through whatever like that's not good
enough and I want to like keep pushing
myself to get better which is what I
really like about GameSpot cuz I feel
like it's a great place to do that so
you know it's kinda hard to think about
where the future will lead especially
right now
but I feel like
as long as I'm I'm feeling like I'm
pushing myself then I'm pretty happy
where I am
cool Lucy do you wanna read the last
question sure this is from Robert J on
the discord with companies doing their
own online version of III for the month
of June do you believe this will result
in a decrease of on-site events and
promote more Nintendo direct style
direct like presentations slash events
for the future yes I cannot foresee III
as we knew it happening again like yeah
I agree it costs an unbelievable amount
of money for companies to put on press
conferences of that size and magnitude
as well as having booth space on the
floor like they would still I imagine
III would become a complete consumer
show in the vein of a pax or an eg X
which is like no bad thing at all maybe
they can find a better balance like the
way the gamescom handles things but I
can see like I don't know people
throwing the traditional PR pipeline out
the window and just announcing and doing
direct as and when yeah I mean the only
benefit I can see to an on-site trade
show is having control over a demo and
not the risk of it leaking I think
that's something that they still do do
we go to like on-site appointments at
you know hotels or whatever to play a
demo of a game because like they could
technically send us a debug version or
something but we when you're multiplying
that by like youtubers and tons of
different outlets the risks go up and
there there are certain publishers that
do really limit codes that come out and
have a lot of strict requirements around
those codes so I can see those kinds of
things happening but not like all at
once like in an e3 setting I do think
like I've been thinking about like work
you
in general evolving because we're all
pretty successfully I would say
telecommuting right now yeah so I'm I'm
just kind of imagining like nothing
really going back to 100% the way it was
but I do really see the value in on-site
events for like like fan events and cons
because I do know there's a lot of value
to those in-person interactions and in
that setting a celebration of games yeah
but but maybe not for I mean III has
already been moving away from the trade
show that we went to when we first
started in this industry in the last
couple years so I just yeah I don't see
that I think that there is kind of over
right yeah I mean I honestly don't think
they'll do pret like Sony Xbox are gonna
do press events or like press shows ever
again just because I think after they do
this they're gonna find that just as
many people watched and they didn't
spend nearly as much money but I could
still see an e3 happening where all that
stuff is online on their own terms not
live and then they still have the show
floor open so people in the media people
who want to be there can still go
through play these games interact with
people kind of like get a feeling of
what fans are what fans think of certain
games in the directions they're headed
and in that sense cuz I think that's
still super important but like the whole
like a whole audience in a stadium with
bands that light up and like plants in
there cheering for updates and games and
stuff I don't think that's gonna happen
and Gow it'll be all plants because
they'll just do it at their company
sites we had fake people yeah yeah I
don't know anything else to add there I
think we covered it oh well do you want
to talk about our segue then take it
away so obviously with the absence of
III we decided that it's a great like
there's still gonna be a ton of gaming
announcements this summer and so we are
gonna be covering those as we normally
would like we've already announced we're
working with CD Projekt RED
to K square enix like all the big boys
but we're also gonna be using the summer
to kind of celebrate gaming and like
help make people realize that it's a
force for good and so we're doing huge
charity drive for Direct Relief who are
helping out with Kovan relief getting
you know protective clothing to people
they have a bunch of stuff that they've
stockpile that they're giving out to
people who need it who to kind of like
do covered relief I guess that's very
circular definition I apologize but so
it's gonna be this great mix of like big
gaming announcements and then we're
gonna be running all these streams with
like youtubers streamers gaming
personalities developers to raise money
and we're gonna hopefully make some
really cool stuff with a lot of our
gaming friends we would love for you to
get involved so please join us on the
GameSpot discord DMS for an invite or
email after dot podcaster guess what
calm yeah email has been looking kind of
dry lately all our questions in the
disparate discord emails like get her
people asking me to join this garden I'm
like all right you're in but seriously
like we announced it on Monday and the
reception's been so great people in the
discord Daniel Moreno shout out to him
and like he DM me today and he's made
his own kind of poster artwork for play
for all which is incredible like not
only has he used the color like the
branding colors that were using but he's
also used the Direct Relief stuff too
I'll share it in the discord it's really
cool and it's awesome it's so great and
it's like we want to do something to
bring people together like I'm trying
not to sound hokey about it but like Rob
Mallory Rob Honolulu should get so many
prophets of this because like he
messaged me and TAM at like 9 p.m. on
the night a week night weeks ago and it
was we'd been talking about the playful
stuff in the background and he just went
we should do this for charity like screw
the gaming side of it we should just be
doing something like we're a huge
company we're huge website like we have
a great audience and everyone is kind of
game [ __ ] over by this right now and
like you know people are losing jobs and
on top of that people are like genuinely
sick and dying and like we're in a
position where we can help and so that's
been a huge motivator for us and we're
putting together the schedule now and
looks it's gonna be really exciting so
if you want to get involved discord yep
and like Lucy said you can email or you
can email after the dart podcast at
gamespot.com
or you can message any of us on Twitter
except for Kelly I don't think I can
message you right no we're just smart
which is smart is no one can no one can
send you the last of the spoilers but
yeah you can with any of us yeah no fear
and we will get you in there as soon as
possible because like we've said it's
been a great it's it's a great community
so far and we'd love to have you in
there seriously I don't think we've had
to like this is kind of unheard of I
guess in huge discord like I'm we're and
we're growing like I'm not saying that
we're like a massive discord right now
but we have such a nice community that
it's like I haven't seen anything that's
been like made me like go do we need to
block that do we need to do we don't
have mods yet and so far I haven't
thought like gosh we should probably my
for this huh we're gonna need him
eventually but like I'm super impressed
to just yeah I mean I shouldn't be that
surprised but I'm just like super stoked
at how well things have turned out
because it is definitely nerve-wracking
right especially because a lot of a lot
of us are very easy to reach through
there and that can set off a lot of red
flags right because it's also like no
one's abusing the like the at here or
the at everyone's or anything yeah I
think I'm the only one who's done in at
here before respectful but also I'm I'm
really enjoying seeing the way that like
you get regular faces and then they're
so welcoming of new people and then the
way that like different branches of
conversation that I wouldn't necessarily
have expected to appear in a gaming like
the photography stuff that people are
sharing as well as like there's someone
in there who just posts like recipes of
things that he
making while he's in isolation and like
recipes it's so cute and like it
genuinely like a comment but who wrote
it in the day I think it was minute but
he was saying like the disk was getting
so big that's like I can't keep up now
because there's so much going on which
is really nice and yeah that's great
please don't yeah and I really want to
show that really quickly Ryan are a
madden 13 on discord who hooked me up
with a t-rex tail and animal crossing
which I needed for my museum display and
they came to my town and really
respectful my flowers are all intact
I can set out like here's some free
stuff I'll pay you for the t-rex tail
like I'll pay you double or whatever
like asked to shop at my store asked
before buying things it was sick and it
was just a great experience and like I'm
just really happy that we did the
discord yeah yeah I mean while I kicked
open the gates start digging up flowers
buy all your stuff I'm just kidding
anyway jean-luc where can people find
you if they do want to email message you
about the discord I could find me at
John XIV if you want to get on the
discord otherwise I have a potato mode
me and bended on predator hunting
grounds which I was a little worried
about I was like I don't know if this is
gonna be a good candidate it actually
ended up being a really great one we
broke that game in some really funny
haven't done with other games so I'm
actually very excited about it
crap I could have talked about predator
I played it that we can I don't I don't
think it'll end up in the video at all
because of copyright but um that game
does have very long like wait times
so during in between the wait times I
just opened up Chrome and we watched
like the predator musical video and like
predator a.m. vs and I think like max is
gonna be the only one it was like this
is for max to enjoy while and he messes
meeting like predator musicals awesome
thank you for that
maybe he'll sneak that in there
somewhere
Kelly what about you um you can find me
on twitter at inky doji co i NK wife do
ji k k oh and as always i'm just as
always for the past month and a half I'm
working on animal crossing guides all
time please support them because I'm
very proud of them and I'm really
excited to be writing guides and I want
to be able to help people learn some
animal crossing and also on the review
strap because that is my actual job we
had a lot of stuff go up XCOM gears
tactics but also we will have a review
predator hunting grounds we just
reviewed fall out 76 wastelanders we're
gonna have an updated review for rainbow
6 siege probably by the time that this
podcast is up so look forward to that we
do like we've done one for warframe just
a games that have changed significantly
since their initial release games that
were passionate about and in reviews
that we want to put out to say like hey
this game has changed a lot in our
opinion that it has changed a lot since
since the original review so the
original ad was still there the
overwatch 3 review will be a 10 out of
10
realistic siege was no well still it has
changed a lot since release lots of
additions that also lots of like like
structural changes to the game look
actually may have been a 7 sorry
could've been was it it wasn't like yeah
it doesn't it's a very different game
yeah Danny than it was now and the staff
opinion of it has has changed you know
it wasn't matched like our assessment of
the game which is the idea behind
updated reviews so that's my spiel on
that alright and Lucy I am on Twitter at
Lucy James games I've been working on an
evolution of Assassin's Creed video
which will be up now if you wanna go
check it out it's all about how the
gameplay the series has evolved because
it's been 13 years since the first one
and now I feel like the Cryptkeeper
but we're working on that I've been to
I'm on you should be watching this week
with Gary Whitta and chastity and Ryan
talking about fantasy films so of course
they got me on to talk about Lord of the
Rings and The Princess Bride West
world's it is the finale this weekend so
expect our breakdown on Monday on
gamespot universe and I've been doing
good news gaming which is out today -
and also like news videos I'm every
Monday come get all your news I'm doing
a lot it's fun yeah
now I'm gonna follow you up with like
one thing you can find me at jacob deck
and what have I been doing
I did a Gears tactics tips video so if
you've played a lot of gears but never
played a tactics game that's the video
for you you should check it out
other than that I started working on a
very big project that I don't want to
say what it is yet because I don't know
when it'll be done but it's gonna be
long it's gonna be a big one and it's
something I'm very passionate about and
I'm very excited so I will also smile
anime future definitely podcasts over
it's done
[Laughter]
but yeah keep in mind Eric keep that in
mind all update in this podcast as we go
but that should be exciting and then
other than that I'm cutting the review
for siege so the fallout video oh yeah I
did a follow up video last week - yeah
36 but anyway we'll see you all next
week bye
[Music]
you
[Music]